foreign
I thought a great place for us to start
this conversation is the idea of sleep
Fitness this is something that you all
are pioneering what exactly is sleep
Fitness and why is it so important to
people
yeah we we came up with this concept of
Fitness that is different from what most
of the other companies in sleep do or
think about right so for us sleep is
literally like Fitness you need to put
the time you need to put the effort and
then the result is usually performance
which really means how you feel when you
wake up and so sleep Fitness means
things like you need to be consistent
with your time the time you go to bed
the time you wake up you need to put the
hours so you need to try to sleep
anywhere between seven and nine hours
and then the results will come and you
will feel great energizing in a good
mood every single day
so when people actively work to sleep
better longer deeper all these different
things how many of them are sleeping
because it's athletic performance it is
mental Clarity and kind of like business
type performance or it's things like
longevity do you see people trying to
specialize or really focus on their
sleep for one of those or is it really
them saying hey I just want to be
healthier I actually want to get more
longevity I want to get better athletic
performance and mental health how much
specialization versus just generally
people realize it's good for their
health and that's why they focus on it
for most it's a great question for most
of the people it's more proudly a
general feeling right because it's
really the feeling of when you wake up
in the morning and how you feel in terms
of energy and in terms of mood then I
think uh there are a lot of people that
now are more into by working and Health
and Longevity and so they know that the
second order effects that will impact
also these verticals but I would say for
most of at least our customers that is
just normal people it's just how great
you feel every morning
describe a little bit the eight sleep
product itself and one of the things
that's been so interesting to me over
the years is it's probably the
technology product I spend the most time
with so if I look at you know the amount
of time I spend on my phone it's you
know I don't know four hours a day or so
if I look at my computer again it's
hours a day but it's not eight hours and
eight hours being one third of the day
seems like man I really better get this
right because it is the thing I spend
the most time with so what exactly does
the product do and how does it work
yeah is is another great point I think
actually Elon Musk had tweeted about how
much you use your car in a week and I
don't remember if it was like two hours
a day at the most so call it 14 hours
but then you start thinking about how
long do you sleep and how much do you
use our product every every single day
and you're talking about almost 60 hours
a week so it's an order of magnitude
almost an order of magnitude bigger than
how much you use your car
um our product is a cover so it's
something that you can install onto any
mattress so if you like your mattress
keep using it then then we don't expect
you to change it you put this cover on
top of it and then you put your bed
sheets on top of our cover and the cover
does a couple of different things first
there are sensors embedded in this cover
they can track everything about your
sleep your respiration and your heart
rate so cardiovascular system and again
respiration in the future would be
things like snoring and sleep apnea and
then based on your Biometrics we adjust
the temperature of each side of the bed
based on your sleep sages and HR and
other factors so there's plenty of
medical evidence that through
temperature and specifically
thermoregulation you can improve your
sleep quality and that is what we see in
our data 9 out of 10 of our customers
report the better sleep plus we see with
hard data that we can improve your deep
sleep by up to 30 percent and your Sleep
Quality by up to 27 percent
so when we talk about this idea of the
cold temperature that is me laying on
the actual mattress I just sleep like I
normally do and it's colder but you guys
have something called autopilot which is
not just leaving it as one static
temperature throughout the night help
people understand kind of what autopilot
is doing and like why is it that
actually maybe changing the temperature
throughout the night could be more
advantageous
yeah so first probably you have heard
people saying oh you should sleep at 68
degrees all night and that is wrong and
it's wrong because your body temperature
changes
um during the night and you go through
different sleep stages and so 68 degrees
could be right for maybe an hour maybe
two hours whatever but definitely it's
not gonna be right for the whole night
and so the first thing we we did when we
started the company was to create the
multiple different settings for
different stages of the night but then
we started applying Ai and ml to that
and so we said instead the new manually
setting this temperature before going to
bed now that the temperature in light
sleep with the temperature in deep sleep
or in Ram we are gonna manage this for
you in real time while you are
unconscious
and so while you are sleeping we capture
your sleep stages we capture your
Biometrics and our AI automatically sets
the temperature that is better for you
our AI also learns from you so we look
at other not toss and turns and delete
quality and sleep stages and every
single day will improve uh the
temperature that we provide for you it's
a sort of autopilot from Tesla but
instead of driving your car it drives
your sleep
so this is not just for Average Joe's
right you have some of the top athletes
uh the top Professionals in the world
sleeping on this who are some of the
people that you're allowed to publicly
talk about they're actually sleeping on
a need sleep
yeah so in business we have um Elon Musk
we have Mark Zuckerberg uh we know the
costla
um Paul Graham I got one so many others
many billionaires in Silicon Valley they
all sleep on our product a lot of CEOs
of public companies they sleep on our
product and then another big bucket is
athletes and so we have Lewis Hamilton
and George Russell they're Formula One
drivers they're we have around 60 70
percent of the Formula One drivers
sleeping on on the Pod
um we have tennis players uh a couple of
the top ten tennis players uh CrossFit
champion and a lot of cyclists so we
just work there was the Tour de France
in France and there was a team sleeping
on the Pod we have the best player from
the Miami Heats sleeping on the power on
on the Pod and traveling with it
um so we had hundreds of
athletes and I think we have more than
40 Olympians sleeping on the problem so
what's so interesting to me is uh when I
played football in college you know
hyperbaric chambers and all these
different kind of Fitness related uh
products it was seen as something that
the professional used right a hyperbaric
chamber is like I don't know 10 15 000
super expensive it's clunky like get in
you zip yourself in this whole thing but
it's got this amazing benefit to it what
you all have built is almost a product
that is good for the professionals but
it's available to kind of the retail uh
individual or the retail consumer as
well is that something that you think
you can continue where it's good enough
for the professional athletes but it's
available to kind of the mass Market
yeah 100 and I think there will be a
portfolio diversification where we will
keep building more products um they will
have a lower price and some others they
will have a higher price and So based on
what you can afford you can sleep in the
greatest uh sleep device ever built to
maximize seriously performance
in in that device I think that you are
already testing it you're sleeping in it
yourself talk a little bit in terms of
uh kind of the company's Mission I think
when I first started sleeping on it and
you and I first started talking and I
was begging you to allow me to invest in
the business uh you were like well
actually the goal here is not just sleep
in this cold environment you wanted to
compress the hours of sleep that someone
had but still kind of increase the
quality so talk why is that goal so
important to you but also how do you
plan to do it
yeah so one of the goals would be can
you get in just six hours the same
amount of rest you were getting in eight
hours can we make sleep more efficient
and the whole point is on my side I'm
obsessed with efficiency as you know
because we're friends and so I try to do
everything possible in my life to
maximize my time and so originally the
first idea of eight sleep came from that
and I say why do I need to sleep eight
hours and the reality is you don't need
to sleep eight hours it's just where
it's something inefficient that didn't
change for the past 2000 years 2000
years ago we were sleeping on a piece of
stone and now for the past 50 years we
have been sleeping on a piece of dumb
phone but the reality is we still go to
bed and we pretend to wake up eight
hours later it's fully refreshed and
that is not possible and so first can we
compress sleep
and I think we can because we can
maximize your sleep performance to
temperature temperature of the bed
temperature of the air light noise and
other factors and then I started
thinking fine even if we can compress
your sleep from eight hours to six it's
still a lot of time what else can we do
for you and so what we want to do is to
substantially scan your body every
single night to detect detect the
potential illnesses that are developing
in your body so imagine if in three four
five years from now some of our products
can stun your body almost like an MRI it
will not be MRI technology would be a
different technology but the results
will be very similar so we can detect
the development of certain illnesses and
potentially even cancer
as you continue down that path obviously
that is a technology problem that's
something you've got to build a company
you got to build technology you got to
figure out how to sell it like like
there's a a clear path right but it's
also one that is uh difficult to execute
what can people do today like very
specific protocols when they go to sleep
other than just sleep on the eight sleep
that allows them to increase the
probability of getting a great night of
sleep are there routines or their
products like what do you do and what do
you suggest other people take a look at
that may work for them
yeah so the first thing that the sleep
doctor would tell you is just to be
consistent and so you need to go to bed
at the same time and wake up at the same
time the reason is you have a biological
clock so you need to teach your body
when it's time to go to bed and when
it's time to wake up and after a while
probably two three four weeks the body
will just start doing it automatically
that is one second you need to put the
time right so you need to try to sleep
anywhere between seven and nine hours I
actually sometimes tell people look just
do this test for a week try to sleep one
hour longer every single day at the end
of the week you will have slept seven
hours more than what you usually do
which is the equivalent of one night
and then you tell me how you feel
this is the second one another thing you
can do is you could do
um a thermal shock before going to bed a
simple way to do it is you you take a
shower and you keep switching between
cold water and warm water 30 seconds
each do it six times that thermal shock
usually really helps you to relax then
if you are in a Nutella or if you can
afford it the the equivalent but the
next stronger is to do a sauna and a
nice bath if you can do that it will
help you particularly even just a sound
that could be really helpful an hour or
two hours before going to bed
the last thing is you can switch all
your lights to Orange in the evening so
let's say after 8 pm and so all the
those that orange will help you
stimulate your melatonin and make your
body feel that it's almost time to work
that
and when you're doing things like the
light how do you suggest people do this
when they're traveling are there certain
hacks that maybe it works at home right
you've got your routine but then all of
a sudden you start traveling and people
like I never get a good night of sleep
on the road or you know I have some sort
of time zone issue what do you do travel
wise that's like a sleep protocol that
works for you
yeah put the lights the only thing you
could do is um there are some
glasses that you could wear and they
will you know let you see everything in
in an orange color that is an option the
other thing is when I travel so I just
came back from Europe I tried to start
adjusting my to the new time zone to
three days in advance so what doctors
say is usually your body is able to
formally adjust only one hour per day 20
time zone so in theory if you go to a
time zone where there is a six hours
Delta it will take your body six days to
fully adjust to that time zone one hour
per day but if you start three days in
advance then instead of being six days
it's just three days right so this is
another thing you can do the other thing
is when you land in you in a new place
the best is to land in the morning and
it's immediately export yourself to
sunlight so the sun will help you to
reset your circadian clock so your
biological o'clock and the other thing
is if it's morning or early afternoon
when you land somewhere else
um just go to the gym so try to
reactivate your body and do some
physical activity so the body
understands that it's not night but is
morning
when somebody asks you cool you're the
CEO and founder of eight sleep I get
what the product does what is it going
to do for me you mentioned that there's
a bunch of studies that you all have
done what are some of the things you all
have learned from those studies that
people who use the Pod end up actually
getting as a benefit of sleeping on a
need sleep
yeah so first you will get better sleep
quality overall it could go up to 30
percent depends on what we see again
nine out of 10 of our customers and
we're talking about thousands and
thousands of customers they report back
to sleep so Sleep Quality you will sleep
better you will wake up more refreshed
this one two you will get more deep
sleep
we have evidence of that as well three
if you're fighting with your partner
about temperature every single night
because your partner likes it what metal
holder that problem is going to be
solved if you have hot flashes like many
women right menopause is an example we
can fix that problem as well and if it's
wet at night or you just feel too hot
then we're gonna fix that problem as
well
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find out more about eat
sleep
uh go on hsleep.com eight like the
number
um
e-i-g-h-sleep.com and there you can find
our product and guess what you have I
think 90 days or up to 100 days to
return it if you don't like it so there
is no risk Mateo I learned something
everything every single time we talk I
always appreciate it we'll definitely do
it again in the future
thank you